join the CinemaSins team in Nashville
for sin week 2023 every year we release
extra videos for our sin club members
and hold live panels with our friends
and fans in person tickets to sin week
are available at a discounted rate for
the month of December space is limited
so head to cinemasins.com cineweek to
reserve your spot today the link is in
the description
[Music]
39 seconds of map porn also it's pretty
bold to follow two minutes of mapping in
the opening credits with yet another
tracking map shot even Magellan doesn't
like this much map the sea snake is
going to die isn't he which one's the
sea snake again I'm getting really tired
of having to pause and check previous
notes every time a character Talks TV
show shouldn't require this much
research remember when we just had to
try and figure out which famous guest
star was the murderer on Matlock each
week and if your next question is what's
a Matlock I'd kindly like to ask you to
get off my lawn I don't want driftmark
maybe you should have spoken up a couple
of episodes ago when they were clearing
up your inheritance and that poor guy
got his face bisected then you can't let
hesitation Eat You Alive luceris not
unless you're trying to egg on
conversations that needlessly drag on we
don't choose our destiny Luke it chooses
us that's a weird way to say some people
are born into rich and privileged
families and some aren't so quit being a
whiny ass kid and enjoy your unearned
fortunes do you want to know the truth
of it
[Music]
I was four and ten same as you are now
four and ten nonsense look we made our
piece with spelling the names all weird
with extra y's and L's but we draw the
line of math just say he's 13 damn it or
I'll add four and ten extra sins in time
I came to understand I had to earn my
inheritance you don't earn an
inheritance it's something given to you
when someone else dies that's kind of
the point but you can earn a sin that's
much easier see I don't like you
in what way sweet boy not so perfect
you're also not still alive at the end
of this episode so renera gets to one-up
you twice in the next 56 minutes these
episodes are long princess rhaenys
which we hope for news of Lord qualis's
recovery Osiris is dead man there's
ripping off the Band-Aid and then
there's being a dick I'll let Cindy
decide which side of that coin princess
rhaenys falls on but that war is not
mine to begin well you sure didn't look
like someone who wanted to avoid war
when your dragon ripped through the
floor killed hundreds of innocent
civilians and roared at the newly
crowned King but maybe I'm just
oversensitive to little things like that
you should leave Dragonstone at once and
go where exactly if the greens have
seized the throne what Safe Haven exists
for renera her kids and their dragons
unless you're offering an invitation for
them to say a drift mark
what babe the babe with the power what
power the power of voodoo hoodoo you do
do what remind me of the babe we've done
this five times before acting like that
assessment matters a single dilated
centimeter to the woman who's going into
[ __ ] labor I don't think the current
mango sized object passing through a
vagina gives a [ __ ] about the previous
four I'm grateful for your long service
to the crown so I'm presenting you with
a choice I wish we'd been shown the
scene where Damon is discussing with the
dragon how I'll be more dramatic if it
doesn't show up until after he said the
word choice all the pregnancies in this
show have unapologetically detailed the
harsh toll birthing takes on the human
body but this one manages to weave
together rhaenyra's suffering and her
Dragon simultaneous pain as part of
their bond against a backdrop of
uncaring men determined to continue
their warmongering see House of the
Dragon you can be worthy of a sin
removal Uncle husbands who show up after
the baby's already been delivered
oh it's him you know the um guy who uh
did the thing you know what I can't fake
that this moment holds any meaning for
me at all all because the show decided
to spend so much time on Sir Kristen
mopey mcmopy face Cole instead of sewing
The Narrative seed of the bearded
Brothers I don't know if this is
delivered or not but this isn't nearly
as moving as I think it's supposed to be
these people are swearing loyalty purely
because of proximity if they've been in
the crowd at King's Landing they'd be
bowing for aegon what's worse is that
I'm certain the show knows this and yet
still brings in the swelling music
because it wants to have its you're the
true king of Gondor moment okay everyone
we're gonna try something a little
different uh in the finale let's bring
in the sweeping music and now stare into
the middle distance middle distance
middle distance middle distance keep
staring keep staring keep staring middle
distance work it work it and cut the
candles oh this is gonna blow people's
minds okay this table's pretty cool in
fact it's so cool it makes me wonder why
it wasn't used for the actual opening
credit it's also there could be books
written on this franchise's obsession
with maps although I guess technically
there already have been Lady of the
Seven Kingdoms and protector of the
realm she didn't bow her head make sure
the audience sees that she didn't bow
her head that's important make sure they
see it did they see it Damon none of our
dragons have been to War uh crazies has
been to war right Damon flew his Dragon
defeating the crab feeder remember or
did you forget about that like Daenerys
sort of forgot about the iron Fleet
there are also unclaimed dragons then
there are the three wild dragons all of
whom Nest here wait there are unclaimed
dragons up for grabs how the [ __ ] is
that a thing if they're so crucial to
well basically everything why isn't
there a wacky race to NAB them jab them
tab them grab them catch that dragon now
I also have a score of eggs incubating
in the dragon Mound yeah but don't they
take years to grow to a size that would
be useful in an all-out dragon war okay
the war itself may go on for a while but
these dragons tend to get through cities
in about half a disappointing finale
amount of minutes so I can't imagine it
taking that long oh hell yeah now we're
gonna see some action well this is just
them talking oh wait there comes a
dragon yeah and now she's getting off
the dragon and now we have more talking
what the [ __ ] God D I've been directed
to deliver her message only to princess
Ramirez where is the princess sure it's
cool that renera has such impossibly
long distance hearing that way she could
wait for Otto to ask for her and then
she could launch on her Dragon at
exactly the right moment to create an
epic entrance is this bridge just under
constant repair like why didn't they
build this bridge wider or build a
specific landing spot specifically
designed for gratuitous look at me I've
got a dragon show boating
how did Renee even get off CRX it's a
pretty narrow bridge and her Dragon
takes up all of it did she climb down
the back and crawl under the dragon or
did she slide down the head I would
rather feed my sons to the dragons than
have him carry Shields and cups I feel
like that's a conversation the Suns
should at least have some saying every
symbol of legitimacy belongs to him sure
but Megan only has those symbols because
you stole them for him which nullifies
the legitimacy part if you robbed a bank
but also took all the receipts and
paperwork with the cash and tried to
pass them off as symbols of legitimacy I
probably wouldn't hold up in court and
if it did we certainly wouldn't be
sending TV shows we'd be legitimately
robbing banks with a crew that had both
George Clooney and Brad Pitt and need
Heist music and what were we talking
about again when dragons flew to war
everything burned I do not wish to rule
over a kingdom of Ash and Bone and
that's writer code for yes we know you'd
love to see a war of the Dragons but
that would be very expensive and
something will likely say for a later
season when we run out of beloved
characters to kill the enemy have
declared war what are you gonna do about
it adult kids also I know Damon plays
The Lovable rap scallion but the way
he's acting here is counterproductive
even for him what good does it do to
belittle renera and risk her standing in
the eyes of the very few Lords she has
at her side
at this point my chief reason for
wanting George RR Martin to finish the
books is so that when the characters
look directly into the camera to read
their titles they'll have more variety
to pull from I've had men whipped
falling asleep on their watch this show
should be whipped for having one of its
most interesting characters sidelined
for the last handful of episodes
taking aowin's tagline in vain your
brother is also dead me Henry niece is
the absolute worst at delivering bad
news this is by far one of the least
incestuous pairings but it's still not
entirely free of it Damon's daughters
are still engaged to his great nephew so
the sin hears that even when you don't
think there's incest there's probably
still incest no matter how strong these
boys are a total blockade of the
shipping lanes if there's one thing Star
Wars Episode 1 taught me as the
blockades of shipping lanes and trade
disputes are guaranteed to make an
exciting story The triarchy have been
routed
the narrow sea is ours playing intense
music and having Emma Darcy raise an
eyebrow does not make the logistical
gobbledygook that Lord Corliss is
spitting out any more exciting dragons
can fly faster than Ravens well
scientifically speaking I think that
depends on a number of factors the
largest of which is whether the Ravens
are unladen and don't even get me
started on whether they're African or
Europe it's being said that as
targaryens we are closer to Gods than to
men who said that could you please cite
your Source because that sounds fake as
[ __ ] and you're hardly impartial the
Einstein puts us a touch closer perhaps
yeah but that Throne killed your father
by giving him leprosy or tatness or
leprootenness or whatever sure that'll
put you closer to the gods but not in
the way you want and only by way of a
funeral I expect you will receive a very
warm welcome she's renier do you want to
jinx him anymore maybe have him say
something like I'll be right back or
tell the audience he just has a few days
left until retirement from the force
where's the bloody maester why did you
wait until now to ask for the maester
you saw a written message being handed
to you then you took another couple
seconds as if trying to recall whether
you could read it come on boros keep
your head in the game this is the kind
of a dentist man that gets baratheon's
killed during hunting trips I want you
to put out your eye cool effect but did
he scoop out his own damaged eye and
replace it with a blue gemstone if so
why wear the eye patch if he's got a
badass replacement eye is it because he
didn't want to go to the Lannisters to
extend the CGI budget is it take
principal Shadows back to his dragon
now phew close call keeping the piece
there now I'm sure he'll hold Prince
Eamon for a little while to prevent any
further violence right right kicking a
child out to fly home in a thunderstorm
not only a child but a prince this is
the worst thing I've seen a Baratheon do
to a child since actually scratch that I
forgot about the Stannis Shireen thing
now I'm just extra sad so here are two
sins for baratheons being awful to
Children this entire climax is amazing
from the shots of agar slowly stalking
air acts in the storm to their desperate
Chase it's the perfect way to end the
season with a promise of more dragon
fighting action to come in season two
also Game of Thrones property decides to
make the most exciting sequence in an
episode barely visible cliche smart way
to use the train in Your Dragon smaller
size to your advantage now I'm sure
luceris will find a spot to land and
hide in this tight Canyon where fagar
can't get him right right
I'm not sure what's more sinful here the
fact that aemon is using this scenario
to try and take an eye from luceris or
that he's under the impression luceres
can hear anything he's saying
Eamon has the perfect eye cup face but
seriously he had to know this was a
possibility right how else was he
expecting to take them out of the sky
wait why are you looking at me like that
eamon's the one that got your son killed
not me oh [ __ ] it was the strong joke I
said earlier wasn't it well the bridge
that was our friendship appears to have
been trampled by a contrivance Dragon so
I may as well tell you you're getting 20
extra sins for this season ends with the
main character breaking the fourth wall
cliche Cali does this show love staring
foreign
but it takes a very long time for
unsatisfying payoff give me the power I
think of you the high septon crowned
aegon in the dragon pit I witnessed it
myself just before I fled on my lease
things that could have been brought to
my attention yesterday
and he chose me as his successor to
defend the realm not cast it headlong
into if I was going into Tashi station
to pick up some power converters where
is Damon is it who who wasn't his type I
came as a messenger not a warrior she
did you little jerk
y